Let's try to find the center
of mass of a uniform object
like a uniform rod.
And let's assume
this rod is length L,
and we want to find
the center of mass.
Now, before I begin
this calculation,
you can probably
already guess that it's
going to be exactly in the
middle, and we'll verify that,
but let's first define what
we mean by our center of mass
for discrete particles.
Recall that this
was a sum over all
the particles in the system.
So we'll take a label
J goes from 1 to N,
and it was the mass of that
jth particle times the position
vector that jth particle
with respect to some origin,
and we're dividing
that by j equals
from 1 to N of the total
mass in the system.
Now, how do we
translate this equation
for a continuous system?
And let me just again show
that we had chosen an origin.
Here was our jth particle
of mass mj and rj.
So what we want to do
is draw the analogy,
and here's how it works-- that
for each discrete particle,
we're going to look at that
as some mass element delta mj.
Our vector rj will go to a
vector for this mass element.
I'll just write it delta m.
And our sum from
j goes from 1 to N
is actually going to go to
an integral over the body.
So let's see how that looks.
So first, we'll do it
with the total mass,
m-- here we're summing
over j-- from 1 to N of mj.
That goes to the
integral over the body.
Now, the delta m,
when we take limits,
because that's when an integral
goes, we'll write that as dm.
So that becomes a
limit over the body.
And likewise, our
sum j goes from 1
to N of mj rj goes to an
integral over the body of dm
vector r going to that element.
So we can say in the
limit that this becomes
r going to that element.
Now, that means that our
continuous expression
for the continuous
object is an integral
over the body of dm r to
that element dm divided
by an integral over
the body of dm.